[bell rings]
[indistinct chatter]
- [laughs]
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
WHY YOU READIN', BITCH?
- BECAUSE I LIKE TO READ,
AND THIS IS A REALLY GOOD BOOK.
- YOU'RE A REALLY GOOD BITCH,
BITCH.
- WHY YOU GOTTA
BOTHER ME, MAN?
- BECAUSE.
[dramatic piano music]
I'M NOT DOING
VERY WELL IN SCHOOL.
I'M READING
AT A THIRD-GRADE LEVEL.
I REALLY DON'T WANT
TO GET LEFT BACK,
SO WHEN I SEE SOMEBODY
READING FOR FUN,
IT MAKES ME FEEL
THAT MUCH MORE STUPID!
AND THEN I GET MAD!
[music stops]
- UM, I DIDN'T
KNOW THAT. I--
THANKS SO MUCH
FOR OPENING UP TO ME--
- SHUT UP, QUEER!
- I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHY--I MEAN,
WHY YOU GOTTA GO THERE?
[piano music]
- I'VE BEEN HAVING
SEXUAL FANTASIES
ABOUT SOME OF
THE OTHER GUYS AT SCHOOL.
- WHAT?
- GIMME THAT!
I'M AFRAID OF THESE FEELINGS
AND WHAT THEY MIGHT MEAN.
IT'S LIKE, BECAUSE
I HATE MYSELF SO MUCH,
I GOTTA
POINT THAT HATE OUTWARD
TOWARDS YOU!
[snickers]
[music stops]
- YOU UNDERSTAND THIS
ON SUCH A DEEP LEVEL THAT--
- I DON'T UNDERSTAND [bleep]!
- WHOA!
- NOW I'M GONNA
PUNISH YOU PHYSICALLY
FOR ACKNOWLEDGING
MY EMOTIONAL PROBLEMS!
- WAIT, WAIT, WAIT,
I WAS GONNA SAY IF YOU
UNDERSTAND YOURSELF SO WELL,
THEN MAYBE YOU SHOULD
TRY WORKING ON CHANGING IT.
- OF COURSE
I WANT TO CHANGE IT!
BUT IT'S THE ONLY
DEFENSE MECHANISM I HAVE
AGAINST DEEPER, MORE TERRIFYING
PROBLEMS BURIED INSIDE OF ME!
[brakes squeak]
YOU'RE LUCKY MY DAD'S HERE.
[piano music]
- [banging]
GET IN THE DAMN TRUCK, SON.
I NEED TO TAKE YOU HOME AND BEAT
ON YOU 'CAUSE I HATE MYSELF.
AND YOU LOOK LIKE
YOUR MOTHER WHO LEFT ME.
THEN I'M GONNA BLOCK OUT
THE GUILT I FEEL
OVER MISTREATING YOU
WITH A RIVER OF VODKA.
- I'M GONNA INTERNALIZE THAT
AND UNKNOWINGLY TRANSFER IT
ONTO YOU TOMORROW.
♪
COMING RELUCTANTLY.